marie et porteuses d'une trisomie 21
ensuite on a marre et garance qui est
porteuse d'un très lourd que le handicap
et ensuite on a à frédéric moïse et qui
lui est porteur d'une anomalie au
cervelet on a neuf enfants dont trois
enfants porteurs de handicap
pupille de l'état que nous avons adoptée
sans des enfants qui ont une
intelligence qui est réel mais ont ils
ont besoin d'accompagnement marie padang
qu'on lui a appris à marcher moi ça m'a
fasciné taquiner lui lui expliquer en
fait le geste pas à pas ce cas de le
dire pour pouvoir marcher ensuite pour
pouvoir monter des escaliers après
l'intégrer moi par exemple quand je veux
et donner à manger à la petite cuillère
j'ai pu apprendre à des cultures c'est
quelque chose que je n'avais encore
jamais fait sont mes enfants de 2 et une
petite fille est très lourdement
l'handicaper
clairement elle ne parle pas mais en
fait elles nous ont communiqué avec elle
de mille façons
et je n'ai aucun problème pour la
comprendre et je n'ai aucun aucun doute
sur le fait qu'elle perçoit énormément
de choses qu'elle me reconnaît parmi
mille qu'elle reconnaît les bruits elle
reconnaît pas dans mon mari ouvre la
porte de la maison
on a fait le test avec d'autres
personnes elle réagi d'une façon très
particulière
elle réagit aux voix la première fois en
fait qu'on a commencé à poser des
questions à marc garance en lui disant
alors comment s'est passée ta journée
marie a été très en colère elle était
petite elle avait trois ans est assez
mis devant nous il a dit elle peut pas
l'anr de dire vous lui demandez quelque
chose qu'elle ne peut pas donc c'est là
quand on s'est rendu compte que marie
dans sa condition aussi elle avait très
bien compris l'état de mariga en ce
qu'elle avait très bien compris à son
niveau qui avait des choses qu'elle ne
pouvait pas fait je dirais que j'ai pas
plus de difficultés aujourd'hui avec mes
enfants handicapés que j'en ai avec les
autres en fait les grandes difficultés
on va dire que je que nous traversons
avec nos enfants porteurs de handicap
c'est le regard justement qui est pesant
et violent de la société qui par
certains moments nous empêchent
d'avancer en fait le projet de loi à cet
amendement qui nous effraie
on s'attarde vraiment
particulièrement sur le projet de loi
enfin des textes bioéthique qui concerne
le dpi et le diagnostic préimplantatoire
des ânes à bruay qui vise aujourd'hui
spécialement la trisomie 21
puisque c'est une anomalie génétique
donc aujourd'hui le débat il décide en
fait collectivement de se dire rien
plantera pas ces embryons porteurs
d'anomalies génétiques et si on va vers
le dp ya finalement collectivement on
accepte que toute notre société est
intolérant tout indiqué moi je suis en
contact de personnes trisomiques adultes
je peux vous dire qu'elles sont tout à
fait conscientes de ce qui est en train
de se tramer et c'est extrêmement
violent pour eux on ne parle que d'eux
sur un caryotype et un chromosome en
plus moi la première fois je vais mari
dans les bras me suis dit mais c'est pas
un chromosome en plus que j'ai dans les
bras une petite fille qui est absolument
magnifique qu'un potentiel évident et
moi aujourd'hui je suis sa mère et j'ai
envie qu'elle soit heureuse mais pour
qu'elle soit heureuse en fait c'est ce
que je ne cesse de répéter c'est que
j'ai besoin de faire alliance avec
l'état et je ne veux plus entendre en
fait ces députés et sénateurs qui parle
de trac quand il parle de nos enfants
qui parlent de poison dans les familles
c'est des choses que je vous cite entre
guillemets qui parle de génisses
c'est des mots qui ne peuvent plus être
employé aujourd'hui moi j'ai fait une
promesse devant l'état
j'ai fait une promesse d'accompagner
tous les jours de ma vie
ces enfants dans leurs difficultés en
leur apportant le plus d'amour pour pour
les aider à grandir à se développer à
être heureux cette fois j'ai envie de
demander au président de l'areq but mais
comment jeu comment je pourrais tenir
cette promesse
toute ma vie si l'état en fait n'est pas
accueillants ils ne mettent pas épouse
est au contraire le seul désir des
parents t'ont en gens soient heureux
mais dans une société qui loge
moi j'essaie de m'en voudra pas
[Musique]